So Leute, da bin ich.
Das ist heute Mini-Stream.
Ich habe knapp eine Stunde Zeit.
Länger geht nicht.
Das heißt wir basteln heute auch nicht großartig was oder machen jetzt irgendwelche tollen
Projekte, weil das geht in knapp einer Stunde nicht.
Moin!
So ich schalte mal gerade meinen Vorschau-Rechner ein.
Der nervt mich die ganze Zeit schon.
Ich soll Windows Update machen, aber ich will nicht.
Hallo? Ich würde gerne hier rüber auf meinen anderen Desktop.
Und geht das nicht? Ah, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
So.
Wartet mal. Chrome starten. Chromium.
Chromium, nicht Chrome.
Chromium muss gestartet werden.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ups. Egal.
So.
Chat, da sind wir.
Wann endlich Jahr des Linux-Desktops?
Ich glaube, wir sind so nah dran am Jahr des Linux-Desktops wie noch nie zuvor.
So nah waren wir noch nie am Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Also ich glaube, das kann man mit, wie soll man sagen, mit Recht, kann man das behaupten.
Wir waren noch nie so nah am Jahr des Linux-Desktops wie 2026.
Was allerdings nicht heißt, dass 2026 das Jahr des Linux-Desktops ist.
Ich sage euch auch mal ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Jahr des Linux-Desktops in diesem Sinn...
Ey, das hatte ich auch letztens.
Der Cache-Installer ist ziemlich fail irgendwie.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es jemals das Jahr des Linux-Desktops in der Form, wie man sich das vorstellt, jetzt geben wird.
Wo dann irgendwie sagen, ja, das Linux-Desktop würde ja bedeuten, okay, Linux hat, keine Ahnung, 10% Verbreitung Anfang des Jahres, am Ende des Jahres 50 oder so.
Das wird es nicht geben.
Das wird schleichend weitergehen die nächsten Jahre.
Aber ich glaube, dass es weitergehen wird.
Trotzdem, dass Wayland bis vor ein paar Jahren noch unusable war.
Aber immerhin, das kriegen sie jetzt ja auch mittlerweile hin.
Seit den letzten drei Jahren so, klappt das ja ganz gut.
Klappt immer besser, muss man sagen.
Ein paar Sachen sacken noch unter Wayland. In der umgedrehten Fall gibt es einiges, was unter X11 auch sackt.
Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das alles viel besser ist.
Doch gab es heute in den News, 5% angeblich sind auf Steam, sind unter Linux unterwegs.
Habe ich heute auch gelesen.
Aber Microsoft, muss man einmal ehrlich sagen, Microsoft tut ja auch alles dafür, die Leute zu Linux zu treiben.
weil man ganz im Ernst so beschissen
wie Windows 11
die letzten 2-3 Jahre ist
und gerade das letzte Jahr über
so dermaßen beschissen
ja, hat man jetzt auch wieder
mit dem letzten Update gesehen, wo
Leute nicht mehr auf ihre Festplatte zugreifen konnten
und sowas, oder andere
Dinger, wo es dann nicht bootet und ganz abstruse
Fehler, es ist so
für den Arsch
was ist
was ist das
oh, vielleicht sollte ich mal kurz
Ich bilde eine Open Source Replacement für APC Smart Slot Network.
Ach, das ist für USVs, die eine Netzwerkschnittstelle haben, oder was?
Oder was soll das sein?
Was bin ich denn sehend?
Alle USVs.
Und wie soll man die anschließen? Per USB oder was?
Also hier per USB kommt die USB dran, oder wie?
Verstehe nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass meine APC-USB eine Möglichkeit hat, da eine Karte nachzurüsten.
zu rüsten ich habe so eine ganz billige das glaube ich moment moment moment
moment moment ich muss ein handy holen
ich jetzt mal gucken so handy stellt das war kurz gucken was habe ich denn für
eine was habe ich denn für eine usv amazon ich habe das garante ich könnte
wetten dass es bei amazon gekauft habe ich kaufe so gut wie alles bei amazon
weil es einfach problemlos ist und man sich nicht rumärgern muss.
Was?
OKS.
Warum will die Amazonette mir jetzt auf einmal einen Passkey unterjubeln?
Was habe ich hier?
Ist das normal?
Passkey?
ok keine ahnung
apc
ich habe eine apc
gibt es da auch vielleicht eine modellnummer oder sowas
product specifications da hat es keine art es hat es nicht
nicht product description gibt's nicht das muss doch irgendein backup ok hier steht weg ups
650 das ding das hat doch im leben keinen slot für irgendeine für irgendeine karte oder das
so ein billiges low-end ding wo soll eine karte reinkommen oder das weil der
ich ja gar nichts wohl wie platz wäre dafür
in chat sagt mir mal dass das hat keine karte oder einschub für karten
break mounted usv ja da kann ich mir das vorstellen das kann ich mir vorstellen
ich habe ein port für die steuerung was habe ich denn für import für die steuerung ich habe
ich habe ein usb ich habe usb anschluss oder meinte den also netzwerk port für die steuerung
habe ich nicht ja hinten waren laden stecker das ist für gigabit in gigabit out zum durchschleifen
für überspannungsschutz da ist da ist kein management dran an der netzwerk steckdose
Nee? Nee. Mach nochmal das Bild. Gleich, wenn ich die Linus-Kiste gestartet habe.
Nee, alles andere kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Okay, zack.
Oh ne, ich hab mich vertippt
Ich kack Noob
Jetzt, hab ich jetzt richtig?
Pause Champ
Pausierungs Champ
Ah ja, excellent
Das ist immer
Ah
Ich muss noch meine Logitech
Sache hier
Starten
Also was meint ihr, ich soll das nochmal aufmachen, das Bild
Äh
Moment, wo hatte ich es denn eben überhaupt
Also hier schon mal nett
Hier, da
Hier, guckt mal, in, out
Das ist nur für
Überspannungsschutz.
Das da oben ist für ein Telefon.
Für ein analoges Telefon.
Rechts. Ach!
Gucke mal da.
Ach so. Ne, ne.
Das ist so ein komisches RPC-Kabel.
Das ist USB.
Da kommt ein USB-Kabel rein.
Das sieht nur so aus wie ein RJ45-Stecker.
Das ist komplett hängen geblieben.
weiß nicht ob es da vielleicht ein handbuch gibt oder so benutzer handbuch
guck da siehst du das eion 45 auf usb
ganz ganz wir ganz ihrer stecker
letztendlich ist es ja auch nur singen in der serial verbindung über usb
das haben wir schon geguckt um arnett
kann man doch darüber ja ja ja du kannst da beispielsweise und es west bay anschließen
oder eine x-beliebige Linux-Kiste
und kannst dann mit NUT
oder irgendwie sowas
das Ding auslesen.
Ja, ja, das funktioniert.
Das geht.
Das funzt.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir gar nicht viel basteln.
Das ist eine Sache von NUT installieren und auslesen
und gut ist.
Ich glaube, wirklich viel gibt es ja gar nicht.
Nein, ich bin nicht
auf Klo. Ich wollte noch testen, ob es noch funktioniert.
so zack zack chatarino da habe ich irgendwas übersehen ist der tisch schon aufgrund ich
habe noch nicht mal hier ordentlich aufgeräumt da ich den tisch war zu ich war zu faul ich muss
erstmal hier wirklich ordentlich alles aufräumen auch die ganzen alten teile verpackungs dinger
und sommer hier ordentlich entsorgen dass hier wieder ordentlich ist ich werde auch
mein sofa hier aus dem arbeitszimmer raus schmeißen weil ich mir gedacht habe die
ecke hier hinten im arbeitszimmer da wo das sofa steht es so far benutze ich eigentlich so gut wie
nie habe ich mir gedacht die die hintere ecke also die sind ihre teil von meinem arbeitszimmer
da wo das sofa steht den benutze ich eigentlich so gut wie nie deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
Ich schmeiß das Sofa einfach raus.
Und stell mein Fahrrad da hin.
Also ich hab hier so einen Smart Trainer.
Mit einem Fahrrad drauf.
Dann mach ich einfach unten so eine Plastikplane hin.
Stell das da drauf.
Dann kann ich da in der Ecke ein bisschen strampeln.
Und daneben kann ich mir sogar noch ein Mini-PC mit Monitor stellen.
Für Swift oder sowas.
genau auf die andere seite kommt dann der basteltisch das ist das einzige was jeder von
sehen werdet.
Dann switch, Swift stream.
Garantiert in nächster Zeit nicht.
Das hat zwei Gründe.
Erstens habe ich keine Ahnung, wie ich das
gescheit streamen soll,
weil ich meine einfach nur, das Game
streamen ist ja blöd da müsste man ja wenn schon das fahrrad auch sehen und alles und
dass das dann muss mich ja liegen und das nächste ist ich bin jetzt in letzter zeit
so gut wie nicht fahrrad gefahren ich werde richtig krass sacken
Ich habe wahrscheinlich ein fdp von 180 oder sowas
hast du den ventilator vor dem rad das habe ich mir auch überlegt als könnte ich nämlich das
könnte ich nämlich 140 140 ist echt nicht so viel aber das kriegst kriegst du easy das kriegst du
easy rauf von 140 bis 180 pax in pax in in no time packst du das das werde ich wahrscheinlich
dann auch machen also das packt sie wenn regelmäßig fährst gar kein problem
ist es nicht so dass fdp sogar auf port fdp läuft auch auf zwei ports chat wie
war das noch mal war das nicht so dass fdp also ich rede jetzt nicht von dem
fdp beim fahrradfahren sondern von dem fdp service ging das natürlich über
Port 21 und Port 20?
Über Port 21 die
Verbindung und die Datenübertragung über Port 20?
Da war doch irgendwas.
Ich erinnere mich schon. Das hat doch zwei
Ports gebraucht, oder?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Äh, weiterer falscher...
Oh Gott, ich...
Monk HW, Alter.
Oh, jetzt.
FDP Port 20.
FTP-Port 20
Datenkanal beim
Genau, Active
FDP
Und dann gibt es auch Passive-FTP
Active-FTP macht doch heute eh keiner mehr, oder?
Naja
Was bedeutet FDP in dem Kontext?
Moment. Das ist Function Power Threshold oder irgendwie sowas.
Functional Threshold Power, genau.
Ist die höchste Durchschnittsleistung in Watt, die Radsportler etwa eine Stunde lang konstant halten können.
Aber nicht im Kontext von Linux, sondern im Kontext von Fahrradfahren.
Das ist also quasi
Wie viel Watt du über eine Stunde lang
Treten kannst
Da gibt es abgedrehte Videos
Auf YouTube Leute das will ich euch jetzt nicht mit quälen
Weil ich weiß das interessiert die meisten nicht
Da gibt es Videos wo Leute
Einen Toastbrot tosten
Mit ihrem Fahrrad
Also sie schließen quasi einen Toaster ans Fahrrad an
Und treten dann
Doch doch 50
50 schafft
die Oma,
die sonst nur Rollator fährt.
50 rollt fast von alleine.
Also da gibt es Videos auf YouTube,
die... Moment, das muss ich euch...
Eins kann ich euch zeigen.
Warte mal, das ist...
Bike
Toaster
olympics eigentlich ist was ist toaster ich werde muss dir mal die beine von dem angucken
alle die die die beiden die beide sind breiter als meine beiden beine zusammen so ein oberschenkel
die hat aber schon besonders große beine 700 watt toaster
Auf geht's, hier geht's los
Toast vor den Toaster, let's go
700 Watt
Der muss 700 Watt treten
Jetzt über
Eine Minute oder so
dass das Toastbrot fertig getoastet ist.
Also, nee, nicht fertig getoastet.
Toastbrot noch länger.
Dass das Toastbrot quasi anfängt braun zu werden.
Das ist kein
Rennrad, Straßenrennenfahrer.
Der fährt nur auf der Bahn,
soweit ich weiß.
Das sind die Fahrräder ohne
Schaltung.
Bahnräder haben keine Schaltung.
Das ist richtiges Tier.
Ich glaube, Robert
Förstermann oder so heißt der.
Guck mal, der Toaster
toastet.
Was bei ihnen alle
Ja, die brauchen richtig viel Power
Dass das Rad überhaupt anfährt
Es scheint anstrengend zu sein, ne
Das ist...
700 Watt ist heftig.
So, mal gucken, ob das Toastbrot ein bisschen...
ein bisschen braun ist.
Oh, ey, ja?
Da hat das Toastbrot getoastet.
Es gibt noch ein anderes Video,
wo der gleiche
gegen 10 Bodybuilder
fährt, aber nur 10 Sekunden sprint.
Also quasi das, wo er richtig gut drin ist.
Und er macht 10 Stück hintereinander.
Besiegt er. Also der Keil geht
richtig ab. Zumindest,
um euch jetzt nochmal was anderes
zu erzählen.
Also der hat jetzt 700 Watt getreten.
Über, weiß ich nicht, so ein bisschen um eine Minute
oder so. Und jetzt halt
euch mal fest, es hat letztens
einer der besten Radfahrer,
also Straßenradfahrer
hat seine
90 Minuten
Durchschnittswatt
hochgeladen
und er ist über 90 Minuten
440 Watt
gefahren
das ist
das kann ich nicht mal eine Minute fahren
das fährt er über 90 Minuten
440 Watt
ja
Und Pogacar hat letztens auch Wattwerte hochgeladen.
Das war auch irgendwas um Kahnung.
430 oder so für 90 Minuten.
Die sind richtig krass, Alter.
Das ist echt nicht normal.
Ja, für ein paar Sekunden, ne?
Vergiss es, Alter.
Also die sind wirklich nicht von dieser Welt,
was da abgezogen wird im Radsport.
egal ob bahn oder straße das ist super krass also das ist wirklich nicht normal
ja meins auch meins auch und ja da gibt es videos zu dass normale leute dieses
bahnrad nicht mal angefahren bekommen weil es zu viel braucht
Naja, das ist schon heftig
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie wir jetzt zu
Profi-Radsport gekommen sind, aber
Ihr wisst ja, dass das so ziemlich eines der wenigen
Sportarten neben E-Sport ist
Die mich interessieren
Wo ich tatsächlich auch ab und zu mal Rennen gucke und so
Leider ist es sehr schwierig
Da Livestreams zu bekommen
Weil in Deutschland kaum was übertragen wird
und auch nicht viele services gibt dafür also es ist schon etwas in der es
das habe ich nicht geguckt
Also für komplett untrainiert und einfach mal aufs Fahrrad gesetzt und drauf ist 160 Watt jetzt nicht schlecht, ja?
Das ist, das ist, das ist okay.
Ich meine, das, wenn du Belastungs-EKG, Moment, hast du ein, oh, da gibt es doch zwei unterschiedliche.
Es gibt Belastungs-EKG und dann kannst du auch noch sowas machen.
Also es gibt
Es gibt einmal das, wo du joggen musst
Und es gibt einmal das, wo du Rad fährst
Das wird für unterschiedliche Sachen eingesetzt
Frag mich jetzt nicht, wo der Unterschied ist
Ich glaube BelastungseKG ist auf dem Fahrrad
Und dann gibt es noch ein anderes
Keine Ahnung, was das genau ist
Da musst du joggen bei, bis du nicht mehr kannst
Das ist echt, okay
Das kenne ich eigentlich nur zum Joggen
Wo ich es bisher gesehen habe
Weil in der Regel brauchst du beim Rennen mehr
Mehr
Rennen ist anstrengender als Fahrradfahren
Also in der Spitze
Oder wie sagt man
Du brauchst im Durchschnitt mehr Energie
Fürs Laufen als fürs Fahrradfahren
So war es glaube ich
Aber 150 Watt
Ist doch nicht schlecht
Ich meine du musst dir überlegen
bei 160 Watt
das fährt
ein Radprofi
quasi rückwärts
für 8 Stunden.
Und danach
ist er noch komplett frisch, als hätte er heute keinen Sport gemacht.
Das juckt ihn überhaupt nicht.
Das ist schon heftig.
Ich hatte einmal, als ich eine längere Tour
gefahren bin.
Das war bei uns hier Richtung Spessart.
Über den Berg drüber und so. Das war irgendwie, glaube ich,
das habe ich sogar auf Twitter damals
gepostet. Irgendwie 62 Kilometer
oder sowas. Das war jetzt nicht die krass lange
Tour, aber mit dem Berg. Und ich hatte
einmal bisher, dass
ich wirklich gemerkt habe,
dass ich Hunger bekomme,
während ich unterwegs war.
Und ich habe da nichts
gefuttert. Normalerweise habe ich immer
so zwei
Riegel mit
mit Limettengeschmack
und so Zeug dabei. Also keine
extra, keine extra irgendwelche
Gels oder irgend so ein Blödsinn. Einfach
nur so ganz normale Powerriegel.
Und
ich hab dann aber nix. Ich bin
dann nicht angehalten, hab was gefuttert.
Also Essen auf dem Rad krieg ich nicht gescheit hin.
Zumal ich halt auch nicht den Dreck wegschmeißen
will, ja. Ich hab dann nix gegessen.
Bin dann noch 20
Minuten weiter gefahren.
Und dann wär ich fast vom Fahrrad gefallen.
Also es ging halt ein bisschen berghoch.
Ohne Scheiß, ich wäre fast vom Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich bin gefahren, gefahren, gefahren.
Ich habe gemerkt, ich kriege Hunger.
Dann bin ich einfach weitergefahren, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
wenn du dann oben bist, dann stellst du dich da mal kurz hin,
futterst einen Riegel, trinkst was.
Bin dann 20 Minuten weitergefahren.
Und ich habe gemerkt, ich kriege immer mehr Hunger.
Ich kriege immer mehr Hunger.
Und dann kam das, was ich schon mal hatte beim längere Strecke joggen.
Dann hab ich vor mir
So im Geiste
Hab ich ein Croissant mit
Marmelade drauf gesehen
Das ist immer deutlicher geworden
Im Kopf
So ein Milchbrötchen war das
Vom Aldi
Und das hat sich immer weiter
So bei mir im Kopf manifestiert
Milchbrötchen vom Aldi
Mit Marmelade drauf
Da hab ich immer mehr Hunger gekriegt
Immer mehr Hunger gekriegt
immer heuer gekriegt und und dann bin ich einfach fast vom fahrrad gefallen
ich habe mich ich konnte gerade noch ich konnte gerade noch weg mit dem fuß um
mich abstützen ich konnte mehr das hatte ich so noch nie
das hatte ich wirklich noch nie ich konnte ich konnte keinen meter weiter
treten und ja zumindest ich bin ein bisschen
bisschen stehen geblieben habe ab einem riegel gefuttert habe irgendwie also ich
war viel wenn das hat 300 milliliter wasser oder so getrunken wenn er irgendwie zehn
minuten sitzen geblieben und dann ging es wieder aber jetzt kommt weil wir es
hier gerade bei wattwerten und so hatten das hat mich so fertig gemacht ich
konnte den restlichen weg nicht mehr über 150 watt treten sobald über 150
getreten habe habe ich direkt gemerkt oder einfach wahrscheinlich schon 140
oder oder irgendwas also sobald ich ein bisschen ein bisschen kraft aufbringen
musste im bein ging ich sofort die beine weh getan ich konnte nicht weiter
konnten quasi konnte weiterfahren aber konnte ich nicht mehr nicht mal
eintreten also das hatte ich auch noch nicht dass das war wirklich heftig
seitdem versuche ich immer regelmäßig war anzuhalten kurz irgendwie mal
rein zu beißen in den riegel kurz auszudrehen und weiterzufahren
naja, zumindest in letzter Zeit bin ich sehr wenig Fahrrad gefahren.
Deswegen will ich jetzt hier hinten, also erstens muss ich mein Fahrrad wieder fit machen für draußen.
Das, was unten steht, also mal abwaschen, neue Kettenwachs drauf.
Und das hier oben auf dem Smart Trainer, das stelle ich mir hier hinten in die Ecke,
mach das Sofa raus, leg Plastik drunter, falls man mal schwitzt, dass es nicht in den Teppich geht.
Plastik drunter, stell mir ein Monitor da vor mit einem Mini-PC für Swift.
und wahrscheinlich hole ich mir dann auch so
so einen Fan
es gibt
das ist eigentlich mega nice
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher wie das heißt
ähm
Swift Fan oder so
Trainer Ventilator
genau sowas
das ist eigentlich richtig high IQ
ja Wahoo geht auch
sei ich egal welcher
zumindest ist es ist es ein lüfter den kannst du koppeln mit deinem smart
trainer
nee das ist nicht das das ist nicht das was ich das ist nicht das was ich meine
das ist nicht das was ich meine es gibt es gibt ventilatoren direkt die
simulieren die erfahrt wind je nachdem wie schnell du in der app fährst kicker
headwind ja das kann sein das könnte sein dass es der ist gleich mal 280 euro
Der sieht verdächtig so aus
Wie der andere, oder?
Das zielgerichtete Fahrtwindmodell
Spiegelform und Position des Körpers
Des Radfahrers während seiner Fahrt
Was auch immer
Der Kicker hat mit anhand von Sensoren gesteuert
Steigt ihre Geschwindigkeit oder Herzfrequenz
So erhöht sich die Geschwindigkeit
Des Ventilators
Das ist eigentlich richtig geil, oder?
Was hast du für ein Fahrrad?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad.
Da habe ich einen Link.
Ich weiß den nämlich selbst gerade nicht.
Das ist ein archive.org Link.
Das Ding da.
Da hatte ich richtig Glück.
nach meinem Unfall vor
2,5 Jahren oder so
muss ich mir ein neues Fahrrad
kaufen und da habe ich hier noch
das gerade im Sale erwischt, weil es ein altes
Modell war und das ist
preis-leistungsmäßig glaube ich eines der besten
Deals ever gewesen.
Äh.
Ich glaube Archive.org
hat gerade ein bisschen Probleme mit den Bildern
und allem.
Weil ich hab, guck mal, das hat neu
3600 Euro gekostet
Ich glaube ich hab
2300 oder irgendwie sowas für bezahlt
Das war echt bester Deal ever
Aber es hat ne 2x11 elektronische Schaltung
Und ich bin richtiger elektronischer Schaltungsfan
Geworden damit
Zumal ich damit auch
So Knöpfe oben
Am Lenker hab
Wo man seinen Fahrradcomputer mit steuern kann, so Seiten vor, Seiten zurück und so.
Da musst du nicht mit der Hand auf dem Handy, äh, auf dem Fahrradcomputer rumfummeln.
Ja, aber so sieht's aus.
Genug Fahrradsachen, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Und die Webseite lädt noch ordentlich.
Aber es scheint nicht so zu sein.
Waitingarchive.org
Okay, das letzte Mal hat er noch Bilder gehabt.
Jetzt hat er wohl kein Bild, äh, kein Bock auf Bilder.
Hier kann man Bilder vor- und zurückschalten, ist klar.
Ja, lass uns mal laden, vielleicht kommt es ja noch.
Zumindest muss ich da wieder ein bisschen mehr fahren.
So, um das abzuschließen.
Was ich mir auch überlegt habe, wisst ihr, was wir in einem der nächsten Streams machen?
Wir machen Niri Einrichtungsstream.
Weil ich habe mir das ja letztens mit euch im Stream zusammen angeguckt.
Und ich fand Niri enorm pock.
Wahrscheinlich auf dem Mini-PC.
Nee, oder? Weiß ich nicht.
ehrlich gesagt ich weiß nicht ob auf dem mini pc ganz ehrlich wenn ihre in der
vm funktioniert warum soll ich dann auf mini pc machen
vielleicht mache ich das einfach in meiner form weiß ich nicht
dann aber auf mini pc machen aber hier aber ich installiere mir übrigens nicht
die CacheOS
Niri Settings, sondern das wird
from scratch
installiert.
Wenn überhaupt.
Weil ich habe mir ein paar Videos
angeguckt heute auf YouTube,
wo Leute ihr Niri Setup gezeigt
haben und ich muss sagen, ich fand
das äußerst
Pocket Champ.
Und was ich halt besonders cool fand,
ist... Moment,
ich zeige euch das mal kurz,
mal gucken, ob ich das Video finde.
Und dann die Stelle da drin.
Niri Setup.
Ne.
hier das da ja so da gab es hier irgendwo hier hier dass das fand ich halt mega was er hier
gezeigt hat muss es kann man gucken ob man das sieht das ist es nicht ja das finde ich halt mega
nice gut überlegt euch mal ihr könnt damit also man hat ja ich muss mal anders erzählen man hat
ja man hat ja oftmals so das problem dass man sagt ich habe hier einen terminal ich habe hier
ich mache jetzt mal stellvertretend diesen editor auf man hat hier den editor und man hat noch einen
browser zum beispiel ja man und man hat hier noch irgendwie einen firefox firefox edition so und
jetzt ist es so bei einem teiling window manager würde sich das hier alles gibt alles geteilt
werden, dann wird das so aussehen.
Das willst
du ja oftmals eigentlich gar nicht.
Überlegt euch mal, was man dann machen könnte.
Da könnte ich nämlich den...
Ah, das kann KDE jetzt glaube ich ab.
Ich stelle euch mal vor, man hätte
diesen Browser hier in der Mitte.
Aber halt so, dass
nur zwei der Anwendungen Fullscreen sind.
Also ne, dass man nur zwei der Anwendungen
direkt sieht.
Das ist das, was er hier
zeigt. Du kannst quasi
switchen.
Guck, von links nach rechts,
da kannst du einen Editor aufhaben
für, sagen wir mal, du machst Frontend-Zeugs.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, du machst
Frontend-Zeugs.
Dann hast du einen Editor auf, einen Browser
auf und einen Terminal, wo du
vielleicht curlen willst oder irgendwas ausprobieren
willst oder whatever. Keine Ahnung.
Und
da kannst du
deinen Editor und Browser hier
side-by-side aufhaben, aber
wenn du im Terminal testen willst,
kannst du auch schnell rüber switchen
und hast dann deinen Browser plus Terminal
auf. Oder wenn du es anders
anordnest, dein
Editor plus Terminal. Aber halt
so, dass du immer die zwei Anwendungen drauf hast.
Du kannst da easy dazwischen hin und her schalten.
Das hat mich
überzeugt heute, als ich das gesehen hab.
Als ich das hier gesehen hab im Video.
Ah ja, jetzt erzählt er ein bisschen.
Genau, ich glaube jetzt,
Ich glaube jetzt jetzt so wie so so wäre es bei einem teiling window manager so wäre es bei einem teiling window manager
guck und na das ist natürlich
Man versteht aber glaube ich weiß meine jetzt kann man herstellen wie verhält sich das mit mehreren monitoren
angeblich soll niri ein super multi monitor support haben ich kann das jetzt selbst nicht
bestätigen weil ich nie nicht ausprobiert habe und schon gar nicht multi monitor aber
soll soll extrem gut sein der multi monitor support sagte hier auch in dem video so deswegen
wollte ich das mal ausprobieren ganz ehrlich ich bin mit kde komplett happy so wie es ist ich kann
damit alles machen genauso wie ich unter e3 alles machen konnte aber mir gefällt
mir irgendwie das ist das muss ich einfach mal ausprobieren kann man auch
vertikals scrollen vertikals scrollen kannst du das bedeutet aber dann quasi
die die den workspace wechseln aber ich kann dir das zeigen ich hab
doch ich hab doch hier irgendwo noch die vm vom letzten mal hoffen wir mal dass
dann auch nie drauf ist wann wann du das machst mit wahrscheinlich am
wochenende dabei sein wollen leute follow bisschen zeller muss sein also
wer also vertikals krollen ist quasi workspace switchen muss er das so
vorstellen du hast unterschiedliche zeilen ja und
jede zeile ist ein workspace und jede zeile selbst es halten infinite scroll
nach nach rechts so niri javas oder noch zum testen hat was da noch
so welcom cash us bla bla so habe ich mache jetzt immer ein paar terminals auf
guck jetzt habe ich das hier hier habe ich ein overview falls man das mal
braucht hier kannst jetzt zwischen quasi horizontal und wenn du jetzt ein
Workspace runter gehst auf Desktop 2.
Black Screen?
Warum das denn?
What?
Black Screen?
Seht ihr wieder was, Leute?
Moment.
Was ist das denn?
Geht's jetzt?
Gucken wir nochmal.
Jetzt seht ihr was, ne?
Okay.
Whatever.
Ich mach nochmal zu, dass das...
Keine Ahnung, was das gerade gewesen ist.
Also guck mal, ich mach jetzt ganz viele Terminals auf und du siehst,
der scrollt immer weiter nach rechts.
Ne, das ist so quasi Infinite Scroll in die Horizontale.
Du kannst dir auch ein Overview angucken, wenn du willst.
So, hier hast du den Kram.
Und wenn die jetzt den workspace switcht
Dann hast du quasi guckt dass kalt war sie vertikal runter in die neue zeile und hier kannst du dann halt auch
Ich bei the way ich weiß nicht wie was die application startmenü ist es einfach nochmal terminals auf
So und jetzt kannst du zwischen den workspace ist quasi jeder workspace ist bei mir so eine eigene zeile
Was das für eine bar noch noch noch
Noctu...
Wie hieß das?
Noctica oder irgendwie so?
Noctalia Shell ist das.
Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob ich das ausprobieren will.
Oder ob ich das ausprobieren werde oder was anderes.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Shell.
Es gibt eine, was ich ganz lustig fand.
Es gibt eine...
Shell, die sich...
Dank Shell nennt.
Dank Shell.
Das ist auch sowas.
Mit Widgets und Kram.
Was ist Fussel Wayland?
App Launcher.
Kann man nicht auch Rofi einfach verwenden?
Mittlerweile?
Gescheit auf Wayland?
Weil dann mache ich das.
Da habe ich schon ein gutes Setting für.
die denkst könnte auch sein dass wir die verwenden mal schauen
wurzel ist besser okay
ja das wird das werde ich das werde ich dann mal ausprobieren
das mache ich aber meine vm wieder aus weil mich das sonst verwirrt wenn ich
gar so viele Sachen hier auf hab.
Power off.
Arschhell.
Da hab ich jetzt noch nix von gehört, aber ganz ehrlich,
mich wundert's nicht, dass es da Linux-typisch
wieder 30 Milliarden
Projekte gibt.
A ready to wayland,
was? A ready to go wayland
Statusbar for Hyperland and Niri.
Feel free to fork this project and customize it.
Ja, ja.
Ah, da gibt es, da gibt es.
Ah, okay.
Dann bookmark ich mir das auch mal.
Arschel.
Also haben wir Noctica oder wie es heißt.
Arschel und Dankshell.
Mal gucken.
Können wir hier alles ausprobieren.
Ich meine, ist das written in Rust?
Das sieht nämlich so aus.
Exzellent, Leute.
Da kann ja nichts mehr schief gehen.
Placingly fast, written in rust.
Alles klar.
Dann muss das A-Shell sein.
In was... Moment.
Denk Shell...
In was sind die anderen geritten?
Core. C++ bestimmt kommt jetzt oder sowas.
Go.
Okay, this is in Go?
Und Noct... Wie hieß das Ding?
Chell, Wayland, Noct...
Noctur... Ne, Noct...
Noctalia.
Top Contributor ist Cloud? Wirklich?
Oh, hör mal auf. Das sind irgendwelche X-Only-Sachen.
Wo ist hier Top Contributor Cloud? Ich seh's nicht.
Hier?
Ne.
Wird man ja eigentlich sehen am Icon.
Oder meinst du, du gehst von aus, dass alles vibe-coded?
Achso, jo, das kann schon sein.
Und was ist das written in?
Ist das etwa...
Ist das etwa written in...
in cute written scheint so das bedeutet wir werden ja auch ein bisschen c++ code finden
ach nee ach der macht mit mit mit python das sieht man auch selten die meisten machen da
direkt c++. So Python
Qt oder Qt
sieht man nicht so oft.
Ohne JavaScript.
WTF, was? Ja, was
ist es denn jetzt?
Okay,
whatever.
Ich hinterfrag das mal nicht weiter.
Es ist alles in QML.
Da hast du ja Embedded JavaScript.
Tja.
Dann schauen wir mal, was es wird.
Das probieren wir dann am Wochenende aus, würde ich sagen.
Da richten wir Niri ein.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich muss diesen ganzen Mist immer ausprobieren.
Aber nur, wenn es was ist,
was mir auf Anhieb gefällt.
Das ist ja das Ding.
Ihr habt es ja, glaube ich,
letztens gemerkt,
Als wir Desktops ausprobiert haben.
Es gab Sachen, die haben mir spontan gefallen.
Okay, es gab eigentlich eine Sache, die hat mir spontan gefallen.
Das war Niri.
Und das ist jetzt was, das muss ich dann auch ausprobieren.
Und obwohl ich, ohne Scheiß, ich bin komplett fein mit KDE.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit KDE.
Ich könnte das bis zur Rente benutzen, KDE.
Würde mich nicht stören, aber trotzdem
Niri sieht nice aus, das müssen wir ausprobieren
Und ich kenne mich wahrscheinlich
Finde ich, das ist ja auch sowas geiles
Wo man wieder viel selbst basteln kann
Bei KDE kannst du nicht so viel selbst basteln
Bei KDE kannst du viel von dem, was da ist
Super krass customizen, konfigurieren
Aber selbst basteln weniger
Und bei diesen Dingern hier kann man immer super viel selbst basteln
Kurze Frage, Max
Moment
Kurze Frage, Max, wie kommt man gut in C-Sharp und C++?
Also, erst mal muss man sagen, C-Sharp und C++ sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
C++ ist so ziemlich die größte Scheißsprache, die es gibt.
In Form, also, die größte Scheißsprache, die eine gute Sprache sein will, ist C++.
Es gibt ja so esoterische Programmiersprachen, die sind absichtlich schlecht.
Also, ne, schlecht kann man nicht sagen.
Die sind absichtlich eklig zu programmieren, sowas wie Brainfuck oder so.
Ja, die sind schon mit dem Gedanken erstellt worden, die sollen abfacken, ja.
Aber C++ ist die Programmiersprache, die mit Abstand am ekligsten und abfackigsten ist, die aber nicht mit dem Ziel erstellt wurde, abzufacken.
So, und C Sharp ist das komplette Gegenteil.
C Sharp ist eine super designte, angenehme Programmiersprache mit einer schönen Standard-Lib, die alles enthält, was man so braucht.
im Gegensatz zur C++ Standard Lib ist die auch
durchdacht zu benutzen.
Ja, die haben auch ein paar Sachen bei C Sharp,
die sich über die ganzen Jahre angesammelt haben.
Warum gibt es irgendwie acht verschiedene Timer-Klassen?
Ja, das ist halt so.
Aber alles ist besser
als irgendwelche Chrono-APIs
in C++.
Woran machst du genau fest mit dem
Negativbeispiel C++?
das problem ist ich habe jetzt noch zehn minuten zeit oder so wenn ich anfange mit
c++ flame dann sitze ich hier noch bis 21 21 uhr ich empfehle dir aber ein video
auf youtube was ich persönlich sehr gut fand das hier also has bed defaults
für viele seiner Features.
C++ ist absolut atrocious.
Zuerst einmal gibt es 20 verschiedene Wege, um zu initiieren.
Also ich finde es fast schon tragisch, dass diese zwei Sprachen so oft in einem Atemzug genannt werden.
Und ich finde es auch schon fast tragisch, dass C und C++ so oft in einem Atemzug genannt werden.
Weil C ist für sich genommen eine in sich recht konsistente, sehr minimalistische Sprache.
aber für die Zwecke, wofür man sie dann braucht, ist C vollkommen fein.
C++ nicht.
C++ wird für Microcontroller verwendet.
Genau, deswegen benutze ich es ja auch öfters.
Welche Weiterbildung kannst du empfehlen?
Keine, keine.
Ich bin ja selbst kein hauptberuflicher Anwendungsentwickler.
Ich habe das alles durchgebastelt
Hier im Stream
Und über
Zig Jahre
Hobbymäßig gelernt
Und
Es hat sich auch schon öfters auf der Arbeit
Ausgezahlt, ich habe ja die ein oder anderen kleinen Tools
Schon gebaut
Die auch eine etwas größere Wirkung hatten
Finde ich dann immer nice
brauche das eventuell für die arbeit demnächst an elektronischem schutz gibt es app entwicklung
pc anwendungen also micro controller kommt halt um 10 nicht drumherum beziehungsweise
je nachdem was es für einer ist dann c++ du kannst in der regel alles meistens sofern die
die zäh sachen anbieten kannst du das in der regel auch mit c++ machen sofern die
halten eine tool chain mit compiler und allem anbieten der c++ kompilieren kann
aber das bin jetzt nicht so drin im micro controller game aber ich würde
behaupten das sollten die meisten haben
Also Espressif für die ESPs, die haben irgendeinen GCC Fork und das Ding kann C++.
Arduino selbst, Arduino ist ja immer C++.
Schön, dass du immer noch am Start bist, seit Ultraskiller.
Das ist schon richtig lang her.
Gnome mit den 3, 4 richtigen Extensions ist so geil.
Oh, ich habe letztens mal wieder fast Anfälle bekommen, als wir Gnome verwendet haben.
Sgt. Silver sagt, ganz ehrlich, ich habe mit Claude eine App gebaut für den Brother LQ Label Drucker, weil mit dieser P-Touch Müll auf den Sack geht.
Oh, ist doch nice, wenn das so gut funktioniert hat bei dir.
Ist doch top.
Ich habe ja für solche Fragen früher immer meinen, darum ist C++ kacke TXT gehabt.
Aber seit ich meinen PC umgestellt habe, also seit 2022 oder so,
und den alten aktuellen PC zum Streaming-Vorschau-PC gemacht habe,
habe ich die Dinger nicht mehr parat.
Also ich habe die noch gespeichert.
Aber die müsste ich jetzt erstmal suchen.
C++ ist am schnellsten.
Okay, da würde ich noch mitgehen.
Natürlich kommen jetzt die
Rust-Leute um die Ecke
und sagen,
Nein, das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Rust Placing the Fast.
Aber ich denke mal, wenn man Leute hat, die ein bisschen ihren Kopf einschalten beim Programmieren,
dann nimmt sich das zwischen C++ und Rust jetzt nicht so wirklich viel.
Kommt wahrscheinlich auf unterschiedliche Sachen an, aber im Kern kann man sagen,
es ist beides so mit das Schnellste, was du machen kannst.
natürlich immer nur wenn du die sachen auch sinnvoll programmiert wo ich nicht unbedingt
mitgehen würde aber da kann ich jetzt gar nicht so viel sagen weil ich ehrlich gesagt wenig c++
debugt habe bisher ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen dass also ich kenne ich kenne gdb
kenne ich damit habe ich ein bisschen rum gebastelt früher also das ist ein debugger
den bedienst du rein über die Kommandozeile.
Du kannst dir dann auch Breakpoints setzen und sowas.
Aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass
wenn man das vergleicht,
beispielsweise mit dem C-Sharp
Debugger, der in Rider integriert ist oder in
Visual Studio, kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen, dass das ähnlich gut ist
wie das.
Aber weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht ist es auch so.
Ich persönlich würde drauf tippen, dass das Debuggen in C++ auch sackt
Weil eine Sprache, die so hart sackt wie C++
Ist wahrscheinlich dann auch zum Debuggen kacke
Aber das weiß ich nicht
Aber das hier würde ich auf jeden Fall auch unterschreiben, ja
Okay, wenn du solche Sachen machst
dann bist du da wahrscheinlich auch deutlich advanced als ich
doch arduino ist okay ja also sagen wir so arduino ist c++ mit ein bisschen
arduino magic dabei so sachen wie vorwort declarations brauchst du dann
nimmer und so und du kannst auch mehr sachen in den file schreiben aber also
gültig ist c++ ist in der regel auch gültiges arduino oder nicht doch doch
bin ich relativ sicher dass das so ist
schreibst du dann ins info welches info fenster von was war was redest jetzt
Du meinst, wenn wir unseren Desktop einrichten, oder was?
Von deinen Tools auf der Arbeit.
Ich mach doch keine Windows-Gui-Tools.
Das meiste sind Go-Command-Line-Tools.
Aber das könnte ich.
Ich könnte tatsächlich in die Hilfe schreiben.
Remember Chico.
Nee, ich könnte eigentlich alle meine Katzen in die Hilfe-Ausgabe reinschreiben.
Also alle drei hier, guck mal.
So hieß das, so hieß das Video.
Ja.
Guck mal, Chico.
Das ist, das ist Chico.
Drei, drei farbige.
Übrigens, in der Regel zu 99%.
Wenn ihr dreifarbige Katzen seht, könnt ihr davon ausgehen, wie gesagt, zu 99, was weiß ich, 9%, könnt ihr davon ausgehen, das sind weibliche Katzen.
Männliche Katzen können das eigentlich nicht sein.
Das ist Chico.
Chico war, weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwo sieht.
Ja.
Chico ist gefährliches Raubtier gewesen
zwischenzeitlich. Guckt mal hier.
Hier, hier, Achtung.
Gefährliches Raubtier.
Guckt euch das an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum
es nur sie ist und Chico heißt.
Standard Vektor Buhl
ist das Schlimmste ever.
Ich fange jetzt aber nicht von C++ an.
Ich riech mich nicht auf.
Oder was hat der Asitoni immer gesagt?
Oh je, gefährliches Raubtier.
Gefährlich.
Komm, nochmal eine neue.
Ich hab keine neue, aber...
Aber ich krieg in letzter Zeit
öfters Besuch.
Und dann sitzt dann sowas Dickes hier in meiner Küche
und will gefüttert werden.
Hast du deine Katze?
Nee.
Soll ich im Discord oder wo?
Muss ich nachher mal gucken
Ja
Guck
Da sitzt ab und zu jetzt was dickes bei mir
In der Wohnung rum
Ja die ist schon
Die ist schon gut dabei
Wem die gehört
Das ist ne die
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Katze aus der Nachbarschaft
Ja ich hab keine Ahnung wem die gehört
Die kommt immer morgens
Die sitzt teilweise seit 6 Uhr
Vor der Tür
Und wartet bis ich aufmache und ihr was geb
Das kann durchaus sein
Dass sie die Runde macht
Die hat mich random besucht
Im Garten
Da hab ich ein bisschen
ein bisschen gut Wetter
gemacht bei der. Man hat sie ein bisschen
streichen lassen, habe ich ihr was zu essen gegeben.
Und seitdem
kommt die fast jeden Tag vorbei.
Och ja.
Die guckt aber
auch niedlich. Ich bin nicht so
der Fan von so super langhaarigen Katzen.
Aber die sehen niedlich aus.
Also von den Augen hier auch
Feines Katzi
Chico lebt nicht mehr
Chicos Essen kann man nicht klauen
Ey, ey, würde ich da fremde Katze füttern
Wenn Chico noch da wäre, dann wäre Chico sauer mit mir
Also, das was ich euch eigentlich noch zeigen wollte
Das war Chico
Hier, gefährliches Raubtier Chico
Das hier ist Original
Katz FPS.
Die erste, die ich hier im Haus hatte.
Das ist noch mit dem iPhone 4 oder irgendwie sowas aufgenommen.
Original
Katz FPS ist das.
Daher
kommt glaube ich auch
dieses Emote
was der Chainlaw gebaut hat
So, das war
Original-Cuts-FPS.
Und
das hier,
die hatte ich leider nur kurz.
Die war schon krank, das wusste ich zwar nicht so richtig,
aber, und doch wusste ich schon.
Die war schon krank, als ihr gekriegt habt.
Die hatte ich nicht so lang.
Die hatte ich schon dreiviertel Jahr oder so.
Und Leute,
die war richtig dick am Anfang.
Die war richtig dick.
Also, das war wirklich massive Chonker.
Und
die hieß, pass mal auf, ich hab's hier unten eingeladen.
Die hieß
Barbie.
Ich hab die nicht so genannt. Ich hab immer die Namen
vom Tierheim übernommen, beziehungsweise
die Namen, die sie vorhatten.
Die dickste von allen, die ich hatte, ja.
Die hieß Barbie.
Was ist für eine Unity Media Boxes?
Das ist so noch ein alter
Unity Media Receiver, der da seit
Jahren rumgestanden hat.
Den wollten die auch nie wieder haben.
Der steht halt einfach da.
Ja, der ist schon ein bisschen älter. Das war noch Unity Media.
Stimmt, wo ist der Cute Mod?
Der Cute Mod hat bestimmt
jetzt seine Lehrerfreundin
da. Seine Referendarin.
Ja, und die hier, die hat immer gerne Fernseh geguckt.
Die hat sich dann so Bilder von Erdhörnchen und sowas angeguckt.
Und da ist die immer, guck mal, guck mal, wie die abgeht da drauf.
Die fand das immer super spannend.
Die ist auch oft erst hochgeklettert und hat hinter den Fernseher geguckt, wo das Viech jetzt hin ist.
Das ist sehr...
Die konnte sich alles angucken.
Vögel-TV, also...
Das kann man jetzt auch falsch verstehen.
Vögel-TV.
Fische.
Erdhörnchen.
Mäuse.
Die konnte sich alles im Fernsehen angucken.
Das fand die alles spannend.
Guck mal, sie leckt sogar so
Also das Eichhörnchen
Das würde ich jetzt auch gerne snacken
Das war auch die einzige, der ich das zugetraut hätte
Vögel oder Mäuse zu fangen
Die anderen waren unfähig
Die nicht
Die war ja manchmal auf der Terrasse draußen
Und wenn da irgendwas gekrabbelt ist
Ist sie sofort auf Tauchstation gegangen
und ist über den Boden gerobbt und hat es versucht zu fangen.
Guck hier, die Eichhörnchen oder Erdhörnchen oder was auch immer, die fanden die super spannend.
Ich bin da auch abgemeldet gewesen, wenn der Fernseher an war.
Das war viel zu spannend, weil die muss das ja fangen, wenn es wegrennt.
Da hat sich Chico unter meinem Hemd versteckt.
Zumindest, ich wollte euch eigentlich nur meine drei Cats zeigen.
Die ich bisher hatte.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, man weiß ja nicht.
Gibt es auch nochmal eine vierte.
Och ja, Chico.
Au, ja.
so eine feine, oder?
Wie geplinzelt wird.
Plinzeln heißt,
wir mögen uns, wir tun uns nix.
Da hatte ich noch ganz schön dicke Finger, oder?
Und Chico, guck mal,
guck mal, Alter, was hatte ich da noch für dicke Finger
und dicke Ärmel?
Gut, da war ich noch
25 Kilo fetter.
Gut.
Genug Katsis geguckt.
Chat.
Ich muss jetzt off.
Habe ich ja angekündigt.
War heute nur Ministream, kurzer Stream.
Knapp eine Stunde.
Wir sehen uns.
Spätestens am Wochenende
mit dem Niri-Einrichtungsstream.
Macht's gut, ciao!